it's a red state boom americans fed up
with rising crime taxes and homelessness
and blue states are flocking to
republican-run states like texas and
florida according to a new census bureau
data report the biggest population
declined was in washington d.c followed
by democrat-led states like new york
illinois hawaii and of course california
the largest increase was seen in gop-led
states like idaho utah and montana
uh wow interesting data there i'm going
to start with you richard i noticed that
no one's moving to california illinois
and new york what does that tell you
about liberal policies and about the
desire of so many americans to have
limited government and more freedom in
their lives
oh thanks for the question rachel a
couple of things here i think it's very
interesting to see where these
population booms are happening but it's
also very interesting to remember that
when folks who leave these yellow these
blue states or these purple states and
they go down to red states they don't
lose their political sensibilities right
they tend to take them with them just
look at the state of georgia georgia now
has two democratic senators and it's
very likely that this will be the most
competitive
repetitive governor's race in american
history between brian kemp and stacey
abrams the same goes for florida where
you see val demings on the ballot versus
marco rubio as well as in north carolina
where sherry b
beasley rather who was a former head of
the supreme court of north carolina is
now running for the senate and has a
good chance of winning so it looks like
when these blue voters or blue state
voters are moving to red states they're
bringing their voting records with them
jason richard brings up a great point
there's a lot of people in texas and
arizona who are saying don't bring your
liberals ideas to our state how is that
going to affect the politics of red
states when we see this kind of
migration
well i live in one of those red states
and that's what scares the living
daylights out of you you're more than
welcome to come here but don't bring
your voting record don't blow it
remember all the reasons you came here
regulations that were reasonable low
taxes you can go out and actually enjoy
the public in the and the outdoors you
can get a piece of land that you
couldn't afford in other types of states
so don't bring those policies to good
intermountain states like idaho wyoming
montana utah even in arizona that's what
going to ruin us more than anything
katie really quick here um they this
this data cited crime and homelessness
taxes but what about covid mandates
aren't these coveted mandates vaccine
mandates making so many of these liberal
cities just
unlivable well first i would say that a
lot of my friends in arizona have a
bumper sticker that says don't
california my arizona so everybody so
far spot on by saying please don't bring
the voting record that you had in your
previous state if it happens to be one
for liberal policies but you're right
there is a lot of there's a lot of
coveted regulation in california
specifically people can drive over to
utah arizona even nevada and have more
freedom in new york it's been
astonishing to watch thousands of kids
get pulled out of school and move to
states like florida new jersey is the
same way so people do want to be free
and that's what they're doing
yeah absolutely tyrus i'm hearing from
young kids who are graduating from
college and saying i want to move to a
place where i have more freedom uh and i
think a lot of it is the are these
coveted mandates as well as the crime
and the and the cost of living in so
many blue states
well yeah it's not just that and what's
the old linda ronstadt song don't make
my red eyes blue i do something similar
to that uh you have to when you like i
grew up in california i'm from
california but now i call the great
state of louisiana home for a damn good
reason i i like my freedom i like the
fact that i'm able to make my own
choices and i think that's important to
a lot of americans but and i also land
on land in montana so my advice to
anyone who's coming from these blue
states you got to roll up your sleeves
be accountable and think about your the
reason why you left in the first place
don't bring your your type of thought
process that got you in the mess in the
first place you guys would have been
voting responsibly you wouldn't be in
this situation so don't come up here and
try to change the way we do things with
your wokeness keep that over there
that's what you wanted but if you're
going to come in have an open mind
because you know southern hospitality is
a beautiful thing so uh you know just
act accordingly and uh you know try not
to blew up our
beautiful that's not gonna happen
louisiana i'm saying that right now but
uh you know welcome but clean up after
yourself don't muddy up our carpet
yeah keep your wokness as you say to
yourself don't bring it over to the red
states all right thanks you guys great
stuff the fastest is up next hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else